this is all rather complex and
complicated but you might remember that
last year there was a huge
interest and fascination into how
exactly martin beshear had managed to
secure that bombshell interview back in
1995 with princess diana there was
subsequently a report by lord dyson that
found that he had used deceitful means
in order to convince her to sit down and
speak so openly about her private life
and one of the people that he made
allegations about was tiggy leg bork who
at the time was william and harry's
nanny and martin beshear told princess
diana at the time that tiggy was having
an affair with prince charles and also
made allegations and showed her
documents that seemed to suggest that
tiggy had had an abortion now ever since
lord dyson's report the bbc have been
making a series of settlements with
various people who are involved the
latest is now to tiggy legborg who her
married name is alexandra pettifer so
it's been confirmed in court this
morning that they have made a settlement
to her they have also issued an apology
which is slightly different from what's
happened with other settlements that
they've made so in court literally in
the last few moments they have said that
the bbc wishes to publicly apologize the
claimant and reservation for these
matters the bbc accepts the allegations
made against the claimant were wholly
baseless should never have been made and
that the bbc did not at the time
adequately investigate serious concerns
over the circumstances in which the bbc
secured the panorama interview now also
i think quite surprisingly tiggy legbalk
alexandra pettifer has actually been in
court this morning now she has been so
private over the years she never gives
interviews she never does any statements
but i think for her it was obviously so
important to make sure the bbc didn't
just pay that settlement but also made
an apology and when you hear from her
lawyer you can understand why because
the lawyer described the impact that
it's had on her and her family she talks
about how earl spencer who was diana's
brother was told about the prince of
wales being in love with the claimant
and also said that then in december 1995
diana then confronted tiggy with those
allegations saying that the claimant has
had great distress
over the years because of those false
allegations of course the bbc now hoping
to draw a line
under this one but we know that lord
dyson said their investigations at the
time were woefully inadequate and i
think this continues to be a stain
on the bbc and very difficult to move on
from